let's be honest we were running long
views so welcome naturally we were being
asked a lot for like people like Jo me
successful music ours
Tommy Robinson obviously someone who's
openly anti-muslim some music artist
not all Muslims house their big shots do
you have enough space for two parents
and Stephen within you know they're not
soon at the flood but they just come to
YouTube revenues do the the mastermind
thing but you can tweet and make an
tweet from yours if you that'd be quite
funny I'd like to see your parents
against you coming to a YouTube channel
I really like to see your parents on
YouTube then to hold the camera as well
it really works
so I brought a bit of a present to this
podcast right so Stephen Stephen lost a
bet this morning right whereas he came
in my flat and I was like look there's a
bottle right if you can flip it first
time I'll dedicate a minute to my next
video like the first minute all to you
right if you don't help big is he go
yeah
how much ego have you got there you go
many viewers have got yeah I meant more
like I'll like make it a shrine to
Steven tries as in like I'll pick you up
like a promise if you want for a minute
not be like anyway but then what was the
thing that if not well he get so if not
right oh it's like I get to choose you
your choice of t-shirt for this podcast
race even didn't flip the bottle at all
didn't even think about you to lots of
free time yeah this is perfect to
announce your new clothing line cooper
ginger property it's a nice t-shirt you
keeping that are you doing I should be
I've got plans I've been I've been
talking with people I want to do a kind
of ironically boots its way life I think
I should be it will be a cost a lot of
money what kind of stuff would you do
you do like something well any yeah but
we've got ideas but I didn't wanna be
one of those be like I'm making a
clothing line because I think everyone
be like move like it's you like but you
are quite fashionable aren't you well
yeah hi Lawrence yeah that's it you're a
fighter and control for printed t-shirt
this is actually quite my fitting is got
nice on you
jeez hey you had a haircut recently
Stephen a half year angles on that hero
fantasy
whoever's gone over that it's done a
bloody good job they get me Tommy
Oh Tommy's the barber not just oh you
can't 200k as well I did expect thank
you very much let's go me too you know
I'm surprised that you're only a two
hundred candle because you've got yeah
that's a good it's very good it's good
you know subscribers well he's young
yeah yeah it's good but I've got a very
unique and glad you want to release that
video
no I genuinely rung him up in mind I'm
gonna release the video said everyone
who makes her fetchers better videos a
[__] and literally an hour later your
fridge it's been a video
videos videos the true Lawrence my face
as well
[Music]
something really horrendous to hang out
with cool people getting involved who
did the more strokes we want an
exclusive for this one we want a title
one takes any brandy magic brand
suddenly went drugs all right much of a
week we're like you know pump has never
mentioned doctor fine and everyone went
well it turns out of taking loads of
cocaine and I've been suppose
the more oxytocin more from front of
auliya r.a there's a yeah the more drugs
you've done the more clear the more
people want you on board cause I'd be
inundated wouldn't he be buck and buck
of them off or if the brand's tricked
all the youtubers into saying they'd
done drugs I'm ending the week after
they went Sorry mate just was earlier
like before let's go it was a stress I
lost it like maybe youtubers youtubers I
think maybe inherently born with this
deficiency they lose their passports
just every youtuber I know manages to
lose their toys I think everyone it's
funny because I think everyone is
YouTube it is kind of just a bit useless
in their own like everyone just daily
tasks and common sense were all was
there anyone when you were there who was
like out of all the lads just couldn't
stop like checking YouTube and to me if
you're on holiday enjoy yourself
everyone's everyone's really have you
use your blue ticket to any of them use
their status to huge what do quite a
female attention was bowing to be one of
them is closet that wasn't
actually Steve last time you were on you
I mean I'm comfortable
Tyndale us same you on how's that work
and it's delayed now but no it's a
instagrams better now you're famous
enough now that you don't need to
anymore
it's not great I won't light it but yeah
comedy in sometimes are difficult aren't
they yeah you know quirky but potent
yeah to really to really get into it
like to be sorry Josh you've got this
there's so much narcissism about there
is a dozen element analysis it's just I
find it a bit jarring how fake it can be
her like carry on everyone you portray
yourself in such a way and that's all
online stuff I'm awfully but I think
just so much more info or Instagram is
the worst without with especially well
how everything's fill out in [__]
Photoshop then all of that like the
women and I like making themselves look
like that authors are massive when
they're just flat a lot of things that
we've had will on three times so not
woman once doesn't need a witness
it's not about buying you like a gift
for this cuz you're the first person to
get the true Jordy podcast hot Rick so
but I just want to say if you can think
of what I should give will as a gift for
the Hutt Rick maybe some you know like
footballers get a match ball yeah you
know
maybe a bongo maybe a t-shirt maybe a
ball maybe a sign ball on the comments
yes I know maybe get you and Alan
Shearer to sign it the kings of the
north of the pretend George yeah you
should set the camera yeah it's when you
arrive and you go good afternoon welcome
thank you very much for coming it seems
the cameras come on its do you want to
do one of those quizzes online where we
look at offensive [__] a quiz on light
well at one of those things actually I
we've been told to do something why have
we been told to do is it heads up again
so good if we need a heads up with more
to watch the video where Sophia spin
sense for a little T they want us to do
right should I get a waste of time I saw
[Music]
this one of us it will be on wills
channel is notoriously litigious why is
she having to go up this little T feller
again because I thought they were made
sunny with you know what I mean just
money beef it means views all right like
it came to a fault it's time to close
the chapter on that because that those
two now are actually solidly decent this
isn't terrible we're a YouTube channel
when they realize that controversy
creates cash and they've gone too far
and it's definitely time to stop now
sometimes they realize well just need
the money so let's keep going don't they
I mean really most people will do that
until it starts to tail off it you mean
why would you stop something you think
is making you a lot of money
there's this short money and then
there's long money so if you take a
different path than sort of gain some
credibility and try and bet other
content you're making then long-term
you'll generate more money than you
would if you just go for the [__]
controversy for the short term so he can
use a 14 year old kid with over a
million subs okay so in this long term
like he's channel I don't know I keep
thinking all like this is gonna die soon
like I II can't keep it up and then
these subscribers we did it we did a
little clip on the true Johnny to
channel don't forget to subscribe
sub to TJ - someone said you missed a
trick in the comments easy you should
call it the - Jory
he's quite clever search engines but
anyway in the in the - Johnny just the
true Geordie - you should know if you're
a good friend of mine but anyway maybe
90k on the second channel anyway we were
talking on the video base about the
quality of videos compared to the views
that they get and how you should be
striving for more and straightaway
people were just name-dropping that day
of kid like here's the biggest abuser of
[__] video as far easier views it's not
true I think he warrants it like he's
putting out a 10 minute video every
single day and it's not good content but
we find his time with the genius that
wasn't like well how many 14 year-olds
are missing the kind of money that those
quickest a month any by playing or
exploiting this system so like he knows
what it's doing and it's not as if like
he's done it once and it's work like
sometimes you have a one-hour video like
these kids can take three or four and a
week mister
if you think of the videos I was making
at 40 you know it was shite I make
videos with 14 year olds and now poor we
love you for you can't get to know
because one is 14 and I suppose if I was
in his shoes I'd do the same thing to be
fair I don't even want to say what I
would do for money so what would you do
but the thing is I would have there's
got to come a point where you turn the
corner at em for some [__] former
credibility surely yeah oh is that I
don't know some people just get lost in
it all don't there must be it won't you
get surrounded by people like wow you
make comedians who are like selling out
- it's like if you're Peter Kay and
you're just getting that certain brand
of comedy is there a point where you try
and level up or do you just sing [__] it
let's write this - the wheels fall off
let's dress up like a woman and release
Christmas songs
jinan I'm saying the difference between
maybe Peter K is like one of those old
style comedians old style Kamini did do
things that dress but right around the
time Peter Kerr was doing really big
numbers in and the average person was
sitting down watching his Shores there
was another group of people who instead
were watching Ricky Gervais yeah and
they were probably both me and if
anything pyaar kiya was making more
money he was making more money in the
short term and Ricky Gervais wasn't
making a lot of money he probably sold
his short baby safer not a lot of money
but in the long term because he was
getting that credibility and he was
making a better form of comedy he is now
the biggest British comedian of all time
and has probably made 10 times repeat I
came in so I'm saying at some point
these content Korea is all of them out
they have to surely try and aim for
better I really hope so
but what I'm saying out there is they
might think the winner no but what I'm
saying is long term you're [__]
yourself right or but some of them
though some of them do think that and
then they set up their own production
companies and just start making
yeah or they changed our Facebook get
into like what Jeff Jones is doing so
apparently he's now changed his facebook
into like a brand so like loud Bibles a
brand he's just turned Chuck Jones it's
not even about him it's too early just
posted on the so funny because I do miss
people just hanging around Covent Garden
you know I never even seen any of that
but yeah it sounds like [__] do you
think oh but you're letting dirt the
dirt off because you think is young and
it's fair one annoying content videos
all right we'll film this like someone
filming at the window and then the crack
Jones going back to the person I should
say allegedly here and then going back
and be like oh yeah it's not good and
make sure each other there's like
anything public is pretty much like
pretty much every public video it's a on
youtubes the yeah because when you know
when you can hear the the victims voice
clearly well they're miked up so
instantly you can tell it's [__] I'm
gonna yeah even if it wasn't he still
like back in the day there were all
those like you've been framed and things
like that
I miss Jeremy bills out there somewhere
beetles about it might be dead if he is
that he's up in heaven looking down
thinking at least someone remembers ya
know a lot of people do do that joke you
do about
[Music]
but the point is with with with those
shows that was like the original YouTube
YouTube yeah bless you
do you not think that we just everyone's
just repurposing no one's really doing
anything particular regionally well yeah
but I think that the problem is that
many people out there making videos that
you're going to struggle for originality
when the youtubes flooded and that's
fair one we're all gonna end up doing
stuff that's a little bit like each
other and sometimes you just generally
take inspiration from people as well but
I think we have to do an original
genuinely original content it depends so
it's so it's blogs but it's basically
broken down into really short comedy
sketches which give it like he basically
changed form of vlog and I know it's
still vlog and if you'd argue that he's
not but he changed that concept was like
look we'll shorten it down and we'll
just cut out all of the bits about the
day or whatever and just make skits for
forming it's not a second and that's no
that was like the first name that came
to my head relative like that's it you
know like that's it I think a lot of
people do I'm sorry I mean people doing
skits before YouTube came along I mean
oh you can go and find skits oh what do
you mean what do you - original concepts
I look for people who are original I
don't mean like we're all gonna end up
stumbling onto each other's ideas I want
people who are just a bit unique that's
what I'm looking for in YouTube people
who I'm not gonna bump into on the
street everyday people who separate
themselves from the rest like maybe I
think you choose more of a platform I
don't think like you you put that stuff
out on TV or you know what you could say
everything from YouTube isn't originally
created but it's just the platform to
distribute of what you make it anyway so
I don't know if the content has to
change its just how you
I guess people sort of think of them as
one and the same really though don't
they like they sort of think of the like
if YouTube markets itself as the
platform where the contributors are the
platform then those two things do sort
of have a symbiotic relationship you
can't release it it's difficult to
separate those two
didn't understand two things just like
those two things are interlinked you
know those two things go together
there's a difference like in terms of
like explained so with TV what you get
then YouTube comes along and it's people
talking to a camera for 10 minutes
alright sit maybe change the way we take
in content I entertain there's one thing
that's not gonna really piss me off is
when people exploit their kids on
YouTube and I like constantly every
video I just putting their kids on there
I don't like it it's not I'm I'm feeling
uncomfortable when I say cuz you know
sometimes you'll see what's around I
watch some random videos and it's like
this is out of all of this so cuz these
kids in 20 years time might not have
wanted to have the whole [__]
childhood shed and you've taken that
option away from them what it's [__]
out there is it silicon jolly or
whatever whatever the cult Irish family
in London you know what I'm I feel
awkward it's almost like they make and
the kids their tricks for the camera do
you find them a little bit unusual it's
like hey goin make sure you do this and
I'm like this is I feel weird like these
are private family moments they're
supposed to be and and now you're in a
situation where you're making that much
money off of youtube like you're sharing
everything these kids are going to grow
up and everyone's going to [__] know
that when you was three years old you
changed your [__] sister's not being a
[__] all over your hands I've seen that
on a video I'm watching thinking what
the [__] am i doing seeing this seed
that's not me being different so this
was another family who were doing pranks
on their children and putting them out
there
yeah about 800,000 subsume and I do
pretty much making them like hey Sakura
Jolie's and so often no really diameter
bomb that was [__] me I think what
they're doing is over-the-top even
sharing as much as they do but that
Daddy of five was just at least one err
really I mean
he got his kids taken off him because of
the YouTube channel Minh he's Alex Jones
[Laughter]
yeah all right well yeah isn't it
what I'm saying is if there's kids in
the video it should be monitored yeah in
my opinion by YouTube and what would you
do I mean God knows do sort of say if
you're the parent it's like it is just
when you make a decision for a kid
that's permanent at a young age and that
it can never be changed almost like it's
something that's I don't think this
should be able to make decisions like
that like even for your own kid so like
I think it 18 if you want to choose a
religion then that's when the religion
should be chosen
I don't argue that in most like you know
before that it's you can't sort of be
neutral up until the age but I think you
should be alone I think it should it
should be making allowed to it's about
like as a parent I obviously if you
believe that you're going to but what
I'm saying is once you baptize or
whatever this child that's it's all
[__] life then boom like you've made
a permanent decision and equally putting
your kids whole footman opera in and out
on YouTube it's something that's more so
that's unchangeable because worse making
it our religious or putting on YouTube
putting a killer on YouTube I think if
it's sharing so if it's sharing to that
degree where literally kids covered in
[__] in the [__] other babies getting
its hands in it and I'm just watching in
shock like I wouldn't [__] dream of
putting family moments like this on 40
years gonna do to the child well
potentially when you're watching a naked
baby and it's [__] three-year-old
sister changing the not be there are
some sick [__] out there who might be
watching that thing and God knows what
that's what makes me feel uncomfy
[Music]
kid who looked like a baby yourself
changing a baby's nappy and I was just a
bit uncomfortable like what the
my day in watching this I I feel like I
should be the uncle in the corner who's
who's in this family not if I'm its yeah
if I'm part of the family it's fine to
say this what's gonna yeah true baby but
again it was just I'm watching this is
[__] bizarre listen to me
to Cissy's intimate family moments when
I'm not in the family it makes me feel
awkward because it's like a there's some
freaky people out there who might enjoy
this in a weird way and she's you're in
a position now where you're making your
kids do tricks and all of that [__] and
constantly having to put out daily
[__] and and create storylines now
to do with your children to keep the
[__] money coming in imagine having
to do that I guess it's been like food
on the table there's been like family
reality TV shows for years now like
we've grown up in a society where that's
always on TV like The Osbournes has done
yeah so they've probably been inspired
by that but like every day yeah the with
The Osbournes I feel like those kids
were what they're 14 15 16 when they
signed up to do that so that like and
that was a pretty good show for its time
and I think that they were maybes in a
better position to commit that know what
the well at themselves in for and
they've grown up as Ozzy Osbourne's kids
but these kids they're just been born
into something they have no control over
how long will they spend the whole
childhood right in that scenario this
isn't even an option why would you draw
the line
I think so me personally if I wouldn't
put any of that out that's fair enough
people wanna Shaw like Conor McGregor
puts a fort out of his newborn son
I've been appreciate that that's a proud
moment you want to share that and that's
awesome but like when it's daily vlogs
of every moment of your kids lives or I
think that's too much I don't know where
to draw the line but daily vlogs is
definitely too much in my usual isn't
because it's sort of it's drawing a
weird line between privacy and night and
what you are assuming is that actually
putting up their whole lives because
you're seeing things whereas they
probably aren't and I think but that is
part of it is is that YouTube gives you
the false impression you are knowing
whatever this is this is the thing that
you were saying about alfie is also a
putting up he's a good example for for
changing so well as diaper again well
you were saying is Alfie puts up a very
happy image of the world two children
who watch him and that is [__] life
isn't always how I've gone from Barack
of the day and equally this family vlog
is putting there might be people out
there watching this thing and well my
family haven't got loads of money my
family don't live in a massive house in
London and my family can't afford this
Sutton the other and my family dawn
never argue so they're putting up a
[__] view of the world but then
could you also argue not to get so deep
if you're gonna put out daily vlogs and
you're gonna put out all of that I think
it's almost unfair to leave out or
you're literally everything misleading
in that sense could you not say the same
about what you say or what you say well
you say I say but I think we're so much
more honest or like yeah but you're not
100% honest I'm very [__] close to
100 but and not 100 and that's the point
you so there's like honesty is binary
there isn't you the honest or not but
what I'm saying is you can be honest to
a certain degree and hold somebody
because you don't want to offend people
so if I think that you're a [__] [__]
but I don't say you're a [__] I say
you're overweight I'm still being honest
yeah what you are doing there is you
you're just that I paint in a certain
picture that isn't the full picture so
when I'm watching this is whatever
Jali's like what
and they appear in a picture that's not
just not the whole truth that's a
[__] version of reality what you're
saying Mary is that the people who watch
your channel are intelligent enough to
work out whether you're so what your
truth is what you're saying is the
people who watch the jolly Channel are
not intelligent what I'm saying is in
terms of percentages of what the truth
is that's coming across on my channel is
a lot closer to 100 and there's a lot
closer to zero maybe they're living in
cloud cuckoo-land and everything's rosy
no I'm not I'm not saying I mean
obviously they don't include all their
arguments and stuff oh because they did
but at the same time I think we're also
gonna give a bit of credit to the
viewers like those guys you know a lot
of viewers are gonna watch things about
laughing no no this isn't true why the
Osborne is not reality you watch the
Geordie sure you watch The Only Way Is
Essex no no those things are anywhere
near the tree but if you but I tell you
what and this has sent something I
guarantee those shores that you've just
mentioned which all feature arguments in
them are a lot course at the reality
then what that is I guarantee I
guarantee you that they are there on
this spectrum and they're all much much
closer than you're giving them credit
for because the only way is Essex is
pretty much entirely made up yes what I
was saying is we're talking about
reality reality I'm talking about
perceived reality so what people are
coming across is what is how close is
this to regular life and I think that
the life that Geordie Shore live is
closer to a regular life of a 20 year
old in Newcastle then that is to an
average foot in family life in Britain
what you're saying to them is they have
the responsibility to portray the
average money life in Britain which they
don't I think you're now saying after
last week you said that
Elfi has the responsibility did you say
this is closer to the truth of what life
is really like and now you're going back
on that and saying actually they don't
know which is it no what I said was
Alfie Alfie is a child's channel
essentially and what my question was was
does he have that responsibility
yes he does I think it does what was but
therefore what does he have to portray
I think he has to give a little bit more
of a realistic view of what life that's
your perceive reality isn't it not yeah
it's a bit of a responsibility when
you've got that much of an audience and
that like they will believe what you'll
then what's your responsibility towards
because like brian says it's its
perceive reality so if alphas perceive
reality is that the world in his boat he
doesn't talk about or think about sex
very often he doesn't take drugs talk
about this one youtuber I think maybe
Philip DeFranco brought it up or Katy
nice night like six months ago I think
that might be one of the reasons Casey
stopped the vlog of being like look you
see all of this good stuff and it's not
real I think they just said that he
didn't feel like he was creative anymore
in that time he was different there was
a difference no when it was both force
positivity on YouTube and how it is a
bit of an issue because you if you spent
like two hours being like right all
these people's lives are great and then
[Music]
maybe this maybe it doesn't help the
mental state of your more impressions
I'm not saying this is a concrete way
where you could be like right go do this
you know you should you should always
100% doesn't but it always feels like
every youtuber we're all we everyone
wants their own truth to be I protect my
own truth but all these other people
have to be closer to the truth than they
are
we've all got this idea that someone
else is not doing that do you know what
I mean
and it's this cuz I think I'd give up
such a close foot and like people say on
the podcast that's Brian that's just who
I am
but they think but that's what I'm
saying is they think that's Brian and
they don't have anything to measure
against because they only get two hours
a week I'm gonna say more wrong people I
know you and I know it is it's very
close but at the same time you know they
don't they don't know that or not you
could as far as they know you could stop
this and be like another brilliant show
guys well done let's go back to my
mansion there they're not gonna know
that because hopefully one day I will be
able to say that if this the problem is
the it's the same it's the same thing
that everyone goes through in every
industry some problem they talk about
authenticity it's look with I guess for
the Alfa's viewers it's their
entertainments they're a sketch an s' to
escape from reality
they don't go at it like that they wanna
they wanna they sort of take themselves
away and enjoy something like with my
channel people don't see me when I'm
down when I'm feeling upset or whatever
they just see me messing around like
throwing stuff at max it's it's what I
want to show you know it's yeah social
media these days people only want to
show the good it's like fate I agree
with what Stephen say in there but
obviously it's just a different form of
content a vlog is it is supposed to in
theory portray kind of what your life is
like that's the general idea of why
people are watching I want to say what
your life is like I'm just saying I
think there's more of a social
understanding it's not actually I didn't
I think people are intelligent enough to
realize that that's not a hundred
percent of it no but what I'm saying is
I'm not asking for a hundred percent
from these people at all and I'm not
asking for every argument what I am
asking is for a little bit more of the
truth of what because I think it's so
fake so what do you think a more
truthful Alfie we do have him like what
would you like him to love to hear I'll
face a check the [__] tux man smashed
us on a single tux on all these [__]
views at least yeah some downside I love
yous the consequence of the tux and then
and then maybe something along the lines
of a [__] like it's true though with
the vloggers and stuff it's like you'll
be watching them and then out of nowhere
you'll just see like Joe never break up
or something it's like it's just
there'll be no no signs of it in the
previous yeah speaks volumes for how
fake it is yeah
we've seen that happen before in YouTube
where everything's hunky-dory and then
one day you never do a video can hear
and it's like oh yeah it's been coming
for ages well on your vlogs about your
footmen life will couldn't footmen - so
how much of the real story are we
getting oh I'm not asking for 100% I'm
asking for even at five to ten percent
of more of what the algorithm I think it
would be honesty is binary see my half
what I think the people watching would
feel a little bit better about their
lives
also think though what you're what
you're asking for from the daily
vloggers is something that because those
guys have sort of inherently linked the
idea that they're sharing everything
about their lives do you think they're
the only ones who have the
responsibility to be honest and I think
media itself is inherently dishonest in
a way because you crop a photo you don't
do 100 you don't do 360 degrees you know
if you if I'm running or something and I
post my run people might I might have
walked [__] half of it do you know
what I mean like I might have cramp
whatever but I'm not posting all that
below but how honest do you have to be
create I feel like
yes that is fake but it is very well
polished and it is very for kids it's
credible content at the end of day like
if we look at a platform we're gonna
take on TV or we're gonna be you know
this new wave form of entertainment
we need characters which are that's all
everything's happy smiley because you do
get that from TV you get that like same
fake positivity I suppose as you know I
feel like maybe we need that type of
creator to give us credibility as a
industry or as a but no but what that
credible but that credibility then comes
from where so what what is remains are
not calling everyone I can't they're not
I'm saying that what makes that credible
and I think what is only interesting is
that a lot of the time what seems to
give those people credibility is they
get a brand deal someone endorses them
from the real world and then they just
cross onto the other side and so I get
the feeling there's a lot of gas in
there the other side of the commercial
side so either they'll they'll you know
they'll appear on this morning they'll
appear on BBC Morning News they appear
and all those things and suddenly
they're credible and the weird thing is
that the validation that they never
claimed to be looking for and the people
they claimed to be taking on are exactly
the people that then give them that
validation so what I'm saying is I think
there's this idea of in the same way
we've sold the Internet of like this
it'll be free everyone will bank in a
really sweet way and all our money or
move in a really nice way and we'll all
have free thoughts and it'll be lovely
there are a lot of people are very
cynical about when that first came out
because they saw that as branding and
people tried to break that down it's in
YouTube's interest for
not to look that way because as soon as
it begins to look that way people like
[__] this dark like why would why wait
Google's helping people achieve things
that are crimes or you know you YouTube
and Google and people have put this in
the comments of that video you put up
there our business and their business is
views and their business is advertising
their business is not spreading your
message and that's the opposite of what
most people say the message of YouTube
is which is getting our voice out there
and taking on sorry but every Smart TV
comes with a YouTube app now YouTube's
making YouTube TV and YouTube's no
YouTube that's just the device you're
watching in yet you're literally
watching on a TV let's not get let's not
get it twisted like the medium is the
message here you are watching it through
whatever you're watching it and there's
a real importance to that and if it's
yeah absolutely because because it makes
it more accessible look we're getting
off topic though no because this is
really it's important to the topic it's
important to the topic that the platform
if you just said the platform's very
important then it is very important if
anything it's like more important we
argue over all silly people or silly
people on it
we're completely missing the point is my
point I think YouTube is the point the
content on it and not to put us all down
is genuinely irrelevant like we we have
big enough egos we think it's important
but YouTube and all those things will
keep going if any of our channel stop
tomorrow
tell us women go toward normal no but
your acting is if I'm saying that to
upset you what I'm saying is I'm not uh
people looked at us and I thought what
am I supposed to disagree with that of
course it you're completely right but
the point is that then that changes we
were having a conversation about the
content and I'm just talking about I
think it would be good if occasionally
alphie just looked in the camera and
instead of being doing the act just drop
the [__] for a second mate and open
the commlite and give us give people an
actual personal moment where you said
you know what it is I'm [__] sick
we're recording every [__] day of my
life and I need a [__] break
something like that not even say [__]
just
just I lived in noticing a healthy for
the people watching them to have just a
little bit of foot in he's just he is
the icon of those people I don't even
he's sort of like a symbol of all of
that lot you know I'm saying at this I
just use him cuz he's at the head of the
[__] tower but Len do you think all
kids TV should be the same then why do
you think Lupita should be like hit you
know all the presenters have to live
this really clean Norman I'm not asking
for not that perfect little kids present
no that's what they're going to be like
I'm asking we're in 2017 oh can we drop
the [__] just a little bit just 5%
just give us something a little bit more
[__] real but what does that change
about what do you think that I was gonna
be healthy for the people watching that
they would not think life is a certain
way is exactly the point that you made
last week I'm back in Lawrence a blast
we got not long service Rico I think
what you're trying to you're trying to
put me against what I was saying last
week which was I'm not you you are you
said that he should be a little bit more
truthful because kids should be happy
yes but there should also have both
sides a little bit of everything of the
world they shouldn't be brought up
believe in crap I think I was asking the
question these is that actually and I'm
agreeing with you no but I'm asking the
question I'm not saying it's actually I
think you're asking it but you're asking
because you know the truth well it's a
leading question that's right but I'm
also saying maybe I'm trying to lead you
down the route of easy actually his
responsibility or are we just angry at
someone who's really not officially his
responsibility is just whatever the [__]
you want to do make money good look good
and that's kind of the problem isn't it
that's a bigger problem than some people
will give a [__] and some people want
and he doesn't have to but I do I give a
[__] as much as I might say [__] and
[__] and all that [__] at least I feel
like I'm given people are young people
who have to do watch this a bit more
about the world I guess that's the issue
isn't it is that it's again that's
perceived reality there are going to be
some people out there who agree with you
he could probably make the complete
opposite
and say well I think you're too dark I
think you talked about I would agree
with that I think you and but fine but
but then what do you like how do you
balance that because he would say to you
tone it down 10%
let me just sorry I like there was
conversations in these cons questions
oh it's mainly just the nerves the
nerves get to me so much I love when
it's going well and there's people
laughing it's fantastic there's like no
better feeling getting a big laugh so I
can Alfie deyes log people in the
comments what you know it's really funny
when I watched a podcast by something I
was sorry to interrupt you sir it's when
they'll go
I could tell Brian really wanted to
punch him when he did okay I must look
like I'm getting really angry when I'm
just sitting there cuz I've spent I was
arguing with you it's like breathing
but yeah but to me is most people have
the arguments that we have and take it
person whereas conversation will just go
great well good conversation their world
will go for a bit and just move on but
but people genuinely think we get really
well done
and that's what makes it so we really do
get wound up yeah anyways Stephen yeah
I've just have seen we are completely
honest about that we are both very angry
you know
just 21 living at home with my mum yeah
it's getting to me though
yeah channels on the downturn do you
enjoy your life comedy though when it
goes well do you enjoy that yeah yeah I
loved it it's just it's just the anxiety
it didn't do me any favors have you
tried drugs Benelli drugs this is the
scale the first time I thought it was
just like a shitty little pub I think I
just wanted to prove myself it was like
at uni so I had a few jokes it just was
just curious there's only one way to get
because I've done a lot of public
speaking so to start with YouTube now
and the more God is good the good news
yeah the more I did it the easier it was
that it's a one of those things you just
gotta keep hammering do you do you
socially awkward in the first place
anyway uh I gotta get to know people and
they open up then yeah is that we put on
tinder no can I see your tinder it's
gone well it's not technically gone if
you reopen the app right now it would
it's quite daunting when you get up in
front of a lord of people and you're
sort of looking around this crowd and
all the eyes are sort of on you yeah and
also there's this expectation that you
are going to say something which they
relate within he's gonna make them laugh
also I didn't really have a character
when I was doing it was just sort of me
so if they didn't laugh I took it
personally and I should have prayed like
just a different persona so that if it
went well or if it didn't go well it
didn't affect my life how much would you
say like percentage-wise how much would
you say your characters like you and
this applies to you as well like Stephen
tries and then bribry character yeah you
do sort of draw I mean you can sort of
tell that's the things if you're drawing
from somewhere that is probably or feels
quite genuine it makes it so much easier
foes
jokester flow it's like my character is
a bit of a [__] like me I just get to
say things that I'd normally think sort
of inappropriate and stuff you know
terrible with Bob the Builder oh is it
the movie is the little fairy is Bob do
Baumeister's in Germany is a zombie
there really doesn't protrude
you should do how to be Bob the Builder
yeah he's an actual character whereas
for me I just feel like when I'm in the
poor but that suit that's true Geordie
they see me with so if I'm with up in
the pub with me mates
um that's exactly the way I am ever
thought you were though like when uh so
when our hangout we're not in the flat
yeah a little bit I can tell there's a
lot going on in your mind you're just a
these things a fuckton like I live the
use of you interpret everything around
you you're really deep singer which
helps for you what you do because
obviously your thing is to break people
down up
situations down and say what's funny
about them yeah but I feel like you take
a lot on board of whatever situation
you're in yeah and I don't realize it
until I remember when I was leaving you
last time again I was like sailor I mean
and I walk then I thought I could just I
remembered you were like taking a lot in
of what was going on you're bright
you're intelligent loudly you're almost
21 I wasn't a self-aware is what you are
you're sort of aware of how you come
across there as I was just like everyone
[__] look at me I don't give a [__]
kicked in but yeah I'm a little bit more
you're quite self aware for because the
comments will just [__] tell you
otherwise I've asked you to do videos
with me before where you thought ahead
more than I would have done a certain
controversial and I think and afterwards
when I thought about it I thought it's
probably best we didn't make that video
than is in a year and but it should be
the other it should be
Mirian and you win and not the other way
around but I sort of recognize eyes are
bright loudly would have been 10 million
subs one day I'll release it cause it'll
not matter that's my 10 million so get
will the 10 million subscribers if you
want to say the videos like Chris MV
with his old-school video yeah
definitely worse than anything he's done
yeah oh yeah little virus ooh
I can't wait for Chris terribly cress
MDMA
MDMA penalty one of my mates took it and
I was asking him about it like and I was
like because we've had a lot of people
with bad drug stories on lately and I
was like just be careful yeah so if
you're ever gonna want to need picked up
it's probably see the logic well yeah I
mean you can see the logic because it's
not some ago at Honda with the funeral I
mean you know look we're not so do you
would you would you just try and get rid
of the anxiety why don't you just try
and get rid of anxiety and do some
bloody stand-up probably yeah
because I've got I've got like YouTube
and stuff so Rose when I did back then
it was just the whole whole sort of
career rested on doing stand-up in ha
get it to go well if you did it now as
well like the people who you just be
saying money on the map every day
because that would be a lot easier for
you if you said I'm doing the gig as a
sideman have proven anything is you
don't have to be good at what you doing
to get a crowd children I mean
I mean that you're I mean that football
talk about their commentary not really
they're great youtubers but footballers
not so much but they've got a crowd
means Toby's pretty and money's good
all right let's stop giving them too
much credit we're not commentators
anymore right us to be do tune in on the
22nd Nords so you would get you would
genuinely get a massive audience now if
you do decide comedy show possibly i
justi that's the thing i need to get
like a good five ten minutes of new
stuff because i've shown all the other
positive i need to work out what my
style is going to be because i don't
have sort of be like i don't talk about
my daily life is usually what i used to
do it and I commonly do that now as to
why could you not use that character
from the videos for it possibly yeah
should have thought [__] me ya know
maybe dress them up a little bit put a
suit and tie on them there are a lot of
young comedians though that do start
with the character don't I remember see
you in like a school uniform school
photo yeah I'd love to say that we can't
leave the Union because you kind of
let's see look my school uniform you
look like a grown man but you also look
like a school boy yeah that'll be a good
angle
yeah like how Colton from The Fresh
Prince used to sort of oh you have that
sort of looks interesting I said dress
up in a school uniform right dress let's
go miss her dress so why do you like
BuzzFeed quizzes so much it's just if
you put those feeds in the title adding
BuzzFeed's
is one of the most searched for things
anything above PewDiePie ironically
BuzzFeed is what what is what is
BuzzFeed are gonna daughter's video do
you want to do some BuzzFeed quiz I'm 32
could be quite funny so what kind of me
zj like will that's one of those
questions you like when you get uh start
freezing and you start saying everything
really listen to ac/dc sometimes but
also Drake it's huge it's not the drugs
or the if I titled it will Ernie's
doesn't do drugs
yeah just a [__] will I need drugs is
gonna get a lot of clicks do you find I
do I feel like I do look like I do them
and just matron that you do someone
smokes weed on our floor sure because
where's that smell coming from well they
go and blame us right but then I open
the door with my red eyes and then you
saying chips upstairs the Tim yeah well
my flatmate tried to walk to the other
one because she works there works all
right if you're listening when you're
editing this story out okay so yes so my
flatmate once was walking
between the towers what does she do and
got mugs for got mugs for a phone so no
wait yes in Stratford Sue's walking to
Stratford yeah two kids came out with
bikes and it's not people live in towers
so what kind of music do you like
what else there's only specific rough is
an era or my recent playlist do you see
that thing right well you listened to
about like five songs that like I've
made it out I've made a playlist about
people I know it's quite a nice way to
categorize music so you sort of so you
have like an album called today yes
Brian album I suppose a bit start one
yeah right now I'm listening a lot 2003
2001 it's classic classic album classic
you can't go wrong
what about you yeah big into the rave
scene about Lords here yeah you know
it's basically race on the Vengaboys
so yeah is the bus coming Oh every day
yeah we're going to Ibiza those were all
good songs but they really weren't very
you know I'm saying this ironically but
they're all about the phone no I do like
yeah the kids like you guys want to try
a doughnut
oh I've saw them before there's
different flavors so we're gonna go
three favourite flavours left peanut
butter definitely want that one banana
and this one is just
remember nice things icing sort of thing
it looks good I had a chocolate one
earlier and it was it was the best owner
of me life donuts very I'm watching me
with instant Helens no no well this will
come out before after after I mean who
cares I've got some questions from the
audience have been asking what people
are actually interested never cheated on
an exam lads oh yeah ever cheat on a
girlfriend no no no I'm actually
thinking I don't know if we will think I
should do this or not about tickles
drive down to the golf course that will
used to work in an interview in them
about and what you were like I want to
get like an interview of what with what
though so I may do like a documentary on
wills life and sort of corn interview
everyone about what he was like but not
but then interview you lust and let you
know what they've said about you big
showers get the dog in will get the
crazy golf car in is there any is there
anyone else we're good school friends
any ideas in the comments let us know
Lawrence have you ever cheated on a girl
god no I would never do that would I let
you off with that would you be up for
doing a meet up anytime soon Lance
yes long YouTube funds and that no are
you doing summer in the city what that
is yeah I think I've been invited I'm
not sure I'd go to a proper one but I
wouldn't say hey did you do a proper one
oh yeah yeah yeah we've got a question
for for Lawrence Africa lads go into
college to study film and TV and looking
to start a YouTube channel but he wants
advice from you on how to get into like
media and that you mean get a job sort
of thing I why university talking to the
microphone Simon why are you eating a
microphone why are you at university
you've got a lot of spare time when
someone offers you a camera take it when
someone offers your microphone take it
when someone offers you a studio take it
doesn't matter if what you make is good
or bad just get practicing and doing it
as much as you can and then ask as many
people as you can to do running which is
like the job where you're the runner on
setting you're sort of just like go
running I just felt like run yeah no but
like - so Winston says you want do you
want to be a runner on set say yes mmm
don't do it for free do it for a nominal
amount and if you don't on a commercial
definitely get a commercial rate and
you'll make reasonable money for very
short space time and in time you can
find out it inspiration was made miron
inspiration in life boys
Stockman's will and there could be
anything you want is there this is
someone that you look at you do your
videos but your inspiration is done
is the idea of Gandhi say in the
homegoing subjugating I'd love to see
you in a pair of Gandhi glasses yeah so
who just give us how you were feeling
summers I've got three four months I
think I YouTube at the time I'd like 20k
subscribers and I was like as soon as
I'm just gonna put this same amount of
time into doing something I love so I
pre filmed before I went home a couple
of videos what the first one was the BG
media video and just literally started
clapping for four on YouTube and then
suddenly that all came came back to you
next yeah with that he was 250 K so it's
amazing how many people who sort of
pause the studies to do YouTube and then
once they really give you to everything
just it just happens have you been
subletting it or I couldn't use like two
empty because it's a student town so
everyone's already sorted there anyway
that's crazy isn't it and the university
wouldn't let you know I was doing okay
what's rent in Loughborough right
Oh week hmm what's rent in LA I think it
was one lad in America who I am who I
know of who had like 75 thousand subs II
was at uni and he said I was going to
take a year off and if I haven't got
150,000 in a year's time I'm coming back
the Union I'm sort of giving up on
YouTube sort of thing and within a year
and a half he had like 1.4 million subs
smashed it
goodbye university what about you
Stephen is there any anyone you look
like any inspiration I made to it Steve
cook and Ricky Gervais I guess just
write in a performer and stuff didn't
even sound English send it off yeah just
yeah just wicked you ace was the main
one he's always been just someone who
can sort of do everything like in any
aspect of the media really well I like
multi like people are multi-talented
yeah I really like the rock is someone
who I think is like and I don't see
myself as that before you start but like
to go frog and new podcasts and show for
the rock to do and the wrestler and then
go into film and then the fact that I
seen him he did a voice for a Disney
movie I wanna yeah continent what was
called but he's sung a song in it and I
was like [__] me this code can do
everything like he's from I think yeah
Doc Brown Doc Brown's very talented game
production how about you them laws could
you go I mean you can go for the obvious
ones like people that Casey nice down
people like no I won him is there anyone
who you're like one day no there must be
someone who you like I've because I know
that UK once you start looking up the
people
you get quite passionate about what they
do I quite passionate about quite a few
people like Kanye West like I know that
you like what he does I'm sorry yeah but
I wouldn't want to be him I'd say you
can be inspired by what you're not
trying to be them you're taking from
what they've done and turning it into
what you do I think I'm just inspired by
people that you see who come with it
doesn't I like people who don't come
with a half-baked idea
I don't like youtubers who do the half
so that's what I've said to you about
that video you sent me the other day I
was like didn't feel finished yeah I
mean and that annoys me when youtubers
do half-finished ideas and go I want you
guys to feedback on it and then we'll
see we'll see what happens you know what
you mean is you want to put in half the
effort so I like someone who's got a
full vision and by someone that Casey
nice that is a I could leave I maestro
online who did like a series with Fox
and he's been with like Chris Bosh Nigel
Sylvester like all these cool figures
and sort of made really nice vignettes
about them and I like what I love is
that people who can make videos that
seem very self-contained but they've got
like that element of truth in them which
make them seem like they relate to the
whole wider world it's very difficult to
do that I don't think many people
achieve it you know and that's why Casey
so good is I think he manages to show a
lot of the world in his videos
inspirational for me it would be strokin
yeah yeah because like I said about
people who can do a lot of things like
he does the UFC commentary and I and I
think you could arguably say in terms of
combat sports he's the best commentator
that has ever been he is a decent
stand-up comedian he's very
knowledgeable considering he wasn't an
MMA fighter himself like he's got black
belts and all sorts and he's a very
decent stand-up comedian and I think his
podcast is probably well it's the best
podcast that's ever been like an action
camera I think it's the best podcast of
all time to be honest with you now
best podcast ever because there are some
exceptional podcasts online what I'm
saying is if you look at the body of
work he's put together at nearly a
thousand podcasts now and you compare
his best work that he's done in those
podcasts to everybody else although
people who won't stand up to that in
terms like the chatty in terms of
variety in terms of the intellect the
stories everything that he's had on the
I think the right is what I'm really
impressed by him the fact that he can do
so many different types of stand-up
comedian podcast our committee whenever
it comes to talking he's just number one
he can speak confidently on a lot of
different subjects like so in his latest
podcast he had people on who were
debating one of the ancient pyramids or
ancient buildings that's been uncovered
and he had the scientist challenge in
one person's opinion and jorgen is
speaking as if he is the authority in
the room because he doesn't that much
research on it he's one of those people
who when he's not podcast and he sits
and reads and learns and learns so when
people try and [__] him on any
subject he's able to just call her [__]
straight away and admire that like his
thirst for knowledge is really
impressive it makes me feel like a dumb
constant names children I mean so I want
to be more like that could I ask a
question yeah what's your biggest fears
like your biggest fear in life
I'd say my biggest fear in life being
skint I've been skinned before I don't
mean skin like compair the sky bill I'm
using like bread and milk can't be
afforded like I'm literally what the
[__] am I going to do I can't let alone
make the rent let alone make the bills
like I know it isn't safe there so like
that's why I'm really [__] motive
aired on YouTube and that because I mean
that's what you worry about what else is
don't worry about
very good point Archie for me like my
own says right now I'm just scared
that's a fair one like to know some of
them on this Brendan Schaub fella of
course he's going to Australia as a
stand-up comedian used to be us a fair
and just as he's booked this trip I'll
show you how someone sent him a picture
of a guy in a hospital bed he'd been on
holiday in Australia bitten by a spider
that haven't amputated his arms and legs
so your fear is not a silly one if it is
if you were in England but if you're in
Australia it's not a silly my worst fear
is sort of being like just in the middle
of an ocean and just not knowing what's
beneath me is like it's funny when I was
starting stuff when I was diving as soon
as I'd gone to the water I'd be like
right I'm under here now and say what's
around us right sometimes you couldn't
but you'd feel better when you're under
the water looking around did you know
what you know it don't like helpless
what I'm saying is that it must be a
very human emotion to be when you're on
the top of the water and because
sometimes the waves are quite high so
you can't really see what's going on so
you know you're in this massive open
space and yet you're helpless
yeah let's the helplessness that makes
you feel like scared because as soon as
I'd go into the wall and I could say
what was around us
I'd feel reassure as if anything under
the waters more dangerous I guess but
yeah because if I mean sharks are faster
than you yeah killers apparently am a
human in swim like two feet per second
and a shotguns from 50 yes so 25
there was loads of them surfers and I
think was earlier taught to cut out with
the water recently because there was 15
great weight shocks just suddenly turned
up yeah they were they were on the
course the helicopter had to go to get
the [__] out the water now this there's
15 great white sharks imagine knowing
that you're in the water and yeah for
basically dead ironically that was one
of my fears before I became a diver I
used to be quite like great white sharks
you so [__]
yeah it is a very on it's an obvious
fear isn't it it's a true fear he's not
it's not really something affection on a
daily basis with with with animals in in
the wild like on foot you can sort of
have a prayer in somewhere you are
beyond
[Applause]
we have any money we're just telling
everyone in Halton that if we keep
talking about it eventually someone's
gonna go yeah and uh but yeah you only
live once I feel like I have to go and
see I want to see like wild African
lions I want to feel what it's like when
they're around I want to see them I
don't know I think I feel like a penguin
I think you'd be a mere cut just like
Timon yeah and I suppose I'd be Pumbaa
Pumbaa is a big fat one like more
questions most expensive clothing or
item of that you own like jewelry
robbing a watch how much are they you
stain them hey you didn't see you didn't
buy them at retail you button
obviously behind the retails you've got
you see southern you yeah do you get
yeah that's why that she won them it's
not countenance get them on the draw
yeah you get them on because people do
the raffles and then how much was your
watch TV I don't know if it was a
present of 150 I'm not like that
oh no it is real Armani that says our
main Calandra particularly I've got I've
got an expensive rings I mean I've got a
ring I that was probably about one and a
half grand mrs. gool ring yeah sometimes
I go to the local markets and see who's
going I think I was a proper [__]
solid gold [__] who shoved the most
farm girls
or as they're known to Stephen Wills
fans who take pity on Wow
that's what's the question is there a
youtuber out there whose Bund the most
fangirls like by a male who who we know
of for more I've seen all right apart
from the obvious one the reigning
defending champ of the world is actually
there is one who's high on is he send me
a snapchat and I thought oh it's from
this guy okay yeah we'll have to include
you on there more often yeah I don't
really want to be you're a journalist
they'll be a little bit frightened to
that I think people are a bit worried
about the acerbic comment they might get
back
yeah that's what I was thinking to be
fair alright hottest teacher at your
school who was that at what level
alright so just what sort of like where
they had teachers so when I think of hot
teacher there's like the teacher comes
to mind is there at each other comes to
your come on let him know what did she
give you what great dishes great so you
got Pepe really was hoping what did she
look like stress size roughly Miss Jones
we had like let's Joan take teacher baby
was charity and it was like this old
woman until year 11 and then Miss Jones
committed change yeah but she was she
was just incredible just just thinking
about now if you're there Miss Jones
what I do know a little bit depressed
I'm here because we can fail our course
work again together what did you teach
you so tech well not much cuz got safe
she taught you what food tech technology
beer she left yeah been asking myself
that every time she left after one of
the students sexually assaulted I begged
her a special just steel mall nice the
thing is it's it's a bit like the office
secretary syndrome in it when they they
might not be that hot because of the
teach I had sort of like and I used to
get told off and sometimes I'd quite
like it mrs. miss was a Miss Parker she
was a the French teacher she she wasn't
that fit but like swimming about her
sure she could speak French but she
wasn't actually French what did you yeah
she's yeah it sounded nice when it came
out of her mouth something she'd had a
big ass on out I did like that
what's he just said I can't [__] hear
I know a beer zambian right for a couple
of weeks now I'm missing all the good
jokes yeah we just have an old man
teacher who used to say to us the German
who used to say to us he said to oral
exams he used to stand at the front of
the class all day you will do oral to me
and then I will grade it and everyone
used to be like if we were all to do a
sketch now what rules would with each of
us a place we try and do some improv now
yeah yeah you love some improv so this
is the true Geordie sketch this is true
we'll only Stephen tries Lawrence
McKenna so what kind of comedy situation
would you like to set up here last time
we did a restaurant last time I was on
let's move away from that anyway maybe
we could have like a two-on-one scenario
are you directing okay you direction
okay okay I feel like maybe maybe a
parent sinking a parents evening
fantastic that's a great scenario yeah
so I might a teacher teacher right and
you are in the parent and child
good evening mr. Brian mr. Brian mr.
Parker I teach little shits tonight
tonight I teach French team Brian here
Brian Brian Brian Brian as we say in
French yes yes yeah I'd say it sounds
the parent if I'm to be honest I didn't
want to say anything oh you're here
touching one of the girls
inappropriately the other day and ever
since he's seen me look and he's had it
in France he's trying to get his
expelled that's terrible you're not a
policeman no I know so yeah no one said
anyone was underage but it's filial I
think it's exploitation is that illegal
yes actually I did have a teacher in my
school that like two years and then he
just came back and everyone was like
yeah we are your right get on the
podcast yeah prisoner on yeah he did
used to teach used to teach media so we
didn't really miss him
after he left but you know really we
covered and he used to call it the
Batcave and he once took a turn running
it was like your bill of course people
no other big people got to say the
sketch took a dark turn
yeah and I mean it always does doesn't
it maybe love life another one must be
enough do love life yet Steven to get
shagged max all right let's rule that
out
you said instagrams working well for you
have you had girls yeah the nude uh
after the last podcast I used the great
phrase I've never received a tip and
this this girl message we went I can't
do you tip but I could do a nice bit of
ass what is this you don't think what is
this in complain did you did you allow
us in the profile and so she was afraid
she was under it in I didn't accept the
message
Stephen did not write you be the guy who
owns the shop and since the since the
underage girl have you had any overage
because you know this I know there's
levels to this but the skills that are
like you know Premier League football
and Ivy League and it's just like what
are you doing 118 yeah you're still
getting getting the chat with them yeah
yeah what's your game like you know what
sure did you spit fire to girls no I'm
okay I can make them laugh so it's it's
quite like that is good if you wanna get
girls I mean I've seen the most average
look and lads who are funny as [__] get
really good-looking girls it happens but
the problem is when she tries to be
serious with you can you go there or do
you always feel the need to like begin
to at the moment it's a little bit
mental so it's great you know we haven't
reached that point abroad cos she's not
like she's totally obsessed with them
yeah it's not like she's dying to get
next for two hours of Stephen and I like
she follow you on twitter yes so she if
you tweet other people so that's when
you know you've got real that's when you
know you've got a bit of a obsessed girl
on your hands when she'll go I seen a
picture you like the other day yeah
that's when you know why
all of summer some of them are more
obsessive than others the wonder you
tend to find liberty to talk about some
people are so just three easy lovers on
Twitter it must be hard for girls who
like being with blokes on YouTube or
whatever like if you're in a circle of
people who shall follow that person and
keep retweeting that stuff and say in
them it's almost like you want to leave
a relationship and end it there but that
you kind of they're always gonna be
around sort of thing yeah yeah
you mean like oh like so if you date
another youtuber not if you're I don't
know if you're a youtuber who do you
tuber or you're just a girl who's in a
circle of friends who knows that person
and they were tweeting the videos and
whatever and you just can't get away
from them yeah yeah like those two
people in America without those big a
prank vs. print something like that and
they were like doing cement
yeah and they broke up and we're doing
all those vlogs where they were like
pretending to be happy about their
single lives yeah and then they just
realize they were better together
because they're both rubbishes
individual I mean would you have a date
and edge for us or a youtuber would you
ever date anyone who works in you know
After Effects
I don't think because it's very much I
don't those girls who are constantly
getting their ass and tits out on that
and would that be like a line that you
wouldn't cross would you'd be like like
forward girls it's respect bother you
know but what if lads are like tweet me
a picture saying yeah you seen your
losses are city girls what the wouldn't
let you I mean they would have seen that
I mean yeah that is sort of an issue
isn't it anyway well yeah well why else
are these losses getting those kind of
views do you not I mean
because they're sort of doing something
that's quite visceral aren't they
they're doing something sort of quite
you know it speaks to visceral yeah
they're getting the one off over yeah
that's one word for it
but that's like for some people that
make them uncomfortable I remember we
once did a job with I I won't shop with
a comedian and he said to me yeah my
wife is a performer and I was like okay
and then what sort of piqued my interest
was I've been watching a series
documentaries about different lifestyles
that people lead and one of them was
about those people who do the webcam
shows for calm girls
Yeah right my cam goes what happened in
this was they used to make lists on
things like Amazon called up like the
wishes publish those and their followers
would send them things like so they just
send them to appear boxes and then he
mentioned he was like yeah she's got a
real thing for heels so a lot of her
followers send her things from a wish
list and I was like she's a model model
performance I yeah she'd just perform a
model and I was like I don't think with
her dildo and you know that she was she
was a porn off but she was a porn
actress but he was really funny looking
and she was obviously like a porn
actress so someone's gonna have found
her attractive in some way or there may
be you know blurred lines but just what
if you don't know what she look like
though she may be in one of those sort
of I saw a picture girl I saw a picture
of him with her not long after when he
went to an award ceremony whether taking
the most dick but like I just found that
a little Bernie I thought that would be
really weird relationship is knowing
that and then he obviously also meant
that he couldn't accept or tell another
guy that asked you to porn actress he
had to say like she's a performer do you
know what I mean if you were married to
opponent the porn actress would you just
say I'm with a porn actress like that so
I wasn't it did work out yeah why
because also then you know that guy can
I suppose you know that if you know if
you're with a girl who gets a body out
on Instagram you know the guy can always
go and look at that anyway
yeah it's funny one Instagram girl sort
of developed morals all of a sudden and
the lake I'm the I'm not being funny but
you get your ass and tits Oh for a
living like yeah why is that a different
kind of currency no it's the starch sort
of acting like what they do is an art
form and all this [__] it's like the
[__] off money do you think the female
body though is like do you think the
female body is quite beautiful [__]
rights it is but doesn't mean we have to
treat it like the [__] Pablo bust at
the castle you just snap in a way and
pull some tits on the internet like if
you had tits would you post yours on the
internet that kind of girl would you be
a private girl do you think I would I
think if I was a I was a woman I
wouldn't be like I think he'd be a bbw
yeah probably yeah it's a given in it
yeah the thing is unlike Lawrence I
could handle a baby aw and I know the
plus sides of having a plus-sized woman
so all you plus-size girls out there you
know get I'm rooting face Levias yeah
all sizes come one come all and that is
actually what he has openings walls see
um some good sex with plus-size girls
like soon anyway yeah either who
received more nudes a beauty will
everywhere I think it's very scary
it's like which of Stephen Hawking's
legs are the worst
well it's one of the most sort of
obsessed over air youtubers man whenever
I flip into it yeah I get all these
girls [__] favor and everything
that's just Simon's like second I know
but they're all finger and all they're
all trickle and down they come from
Simon and then they come to you and then
they filter and down a major T there's
not wrong with cast off smile honestly
do you think not an Instagram
what I find funny is sometimes I'm going
I said it's like I'm going through like
you know people do the likes on
Instagram oh yeah I go through and then
it will just be you on the train or
whatever and you're bored you're like
I'll have a little glance on the the
recommended don't worry though that
people are looking over your shoulder
and going oh you know it's really cool
I've heard like women like give you like
a sandwich or whatever and they
literally be like this Brazilian awesome
me for in Instagram and I'll just
literally fall oh yeah thanks and I do
enjoy the shock yeah I like shocking
people I've always had a bit of owners
yeah it's fun and it yeah yeah it's
funny when you see someone who's a bit
just totally I like awkwardness and
being so comfortable within the middle
of the chaos that must be used while
you'll enjoy oh yeah I really enjoy say
the most appropriate yeah I think that
with family a lot don't speak to me
anymore
it's all it is awkward though when you
first meet someone and you like making
lockwood jokes
I like fringe enormous I love cringing
moments really on the bribry video that
the last one it was it was so bad but
then I think there was times where I
watch her back and I was like it crossed
over into bad very creepy but then there
was some people leaving comments ate all
that was so cringe and I was like that
was exactly what I was going for isn't
it like bro-bro was so intense it was
just amazing it is an intense story I
went overboard with it in retrospect I
wish stuff could have done it but I
wasn't really happy with it when I
uploaded it but I've spent that many
that many scenes there doing these
bloody different angles I was like let's
just put this [__] tip out I just want
to be you always want it to be a bit
better in a bit funnier if you're doing
if you're doing a sketch
or a parody or whatever I think I never
ever feel up the only singer I'm not
really a happy with anything I put out
ever really other occasions but the gym
video was hot me with every millisecond
I wanna see you do different kinds of
videos oh me too well I'm just starting
to vlog today that's hence why Stevens
wearing this t-shirt good that's that's
me brunch no I do want to see you do
other stuff it's pretty quick to be fair
oh I think outside of your room and he's
and even if you're just talking
different yes yeah
do you agree probably definitely would
be different yeah I think you've got
very likeable personality so you can
turn you had two different things like
you know people's people watch it and
enjoy it do as a favor and get Steven
really drunk and vlog that yes do in his
chest
I am what color is that like it's sort
of it's a strawberry blonde yeah this is
ginger look what I do color correct on
on like Oh probably a pro let's put it
on HD it just goes really ginger so
that's what happens yeah the things
differ you craft so you don't have to
ginger here oh yes yeah like it's not
ginger ginger is like an Irish girl yeah
it's like abuse alike
like if I ever drop the video I'm like
all right good comment Steven choices
ginger that's all my comments are but
it's good release it filters all of my
negative comments outs everything that
was
will your teeth look yellow or will yes
your head square it's all gone now
sevens abusing Steven instead so it's in
the fun I'm happy for you yeah it's
still the facts are you still is tricky
I mean here's white you have the caught
in coat the features I've got I've got a
good face for comedy you're very
recognizable yeah you've got tiny yes
but they poke at yeah you're like a
white world smiles for the sauce yeah
that's the look yeah yeah I'm gonna have
little Jaden he'll be wearing dresses
isn't quite sort of freediving for this
is something Will Smith's son he's being
raised a little too free though I think
Will Smith said that he wish he
disciplined him more cuz he turned out
to be a bit of an [__] or something
at one point they let him discipline
himself for like most of his life and
know that pisses me off just to listen
to that why a child discipline and
themselves as much I'm gonna know what's
best for them what's the point of
informing parents and adults man tell
you what let's just let the kids [__]
run wild
yeah I could primates more misbehaving
children this is the last video you're
gonna do on BJ media yes please yeah
you're makin yeah the Mik and fake beef
for views and all now it's like to me
that's the end of their credibility is
is what credibility you can they have
now and therefore it's still a big thing
because I mean I talk about stuff that
happens this week net so I'm like right
look I've never mean another BG media
all right this this week's happened if I
do this video I'll talk for five minutes
and every single comment be like well
why didn't this there's so many of the
channels have jumped on the bandwagon of
BG media their whole channels just BG
but they've sort of ruined it have been
I feel like there's a lot of that goes
on whenever there's a new trend that's
become the technique of how to get views
on YouTube is trend German yeah but the
thing is I don't mean people who do that
as long as the videos are good the
problem is is the 99% who do that when
the videos are [__] you know I mean I've
seen some people who use their kids I
mean when we talk about the kids think
yeah I do see some parents who also use
their kids as marketing tools yeah so
it's not so much that they use them in
the stories like you know like I shat
himself whatever they use them more like
that as the presenters and the parents
will be a director sort of yeah and it's
it's like oh you got it did you get a
free pair of you know Nikes there what
have you got and the kill be like hey
guys welcome back to this and you're
like well that's not most beautiful
channel per month in the world to kids
channel opens its yeah the kids toys TV
just like 700 million views a month 6
million views a month yeah
this is what I want to do is with you is
you should just we should get some toys
and open them on the podcast and just
try and do a more original child's toy
out on the second shot oh yeah
problem time Johnny saw some young
people's problems I mean all right guys
my name's did don't mention my name and
I'm 20 I've recently found out my ex of
two years we broke up a month ago is
seeing one of my mates we have fairly
been fairly close
we was fairly close few years ago I have
already cut ties with him she also
started dating someone else the day
after we broke up which suggests he was
already there I matched one of her good
friends on tinder and we started talking
do I dropped to her level and bang her
friend brackets decent-looking
or do I stay clear cheers boys Wow huge
drop like a top almost the reason
blending the tables saying well I think
you know what she's done to him is is
poor yeah on her path
he shouldn't he should react in spite
yeah but you know if he won't you
shouldn't you know go for this girl to
get back at her know if he likes it you
know and as he's putting brackets she's
decent looking yeah why not all the more
for it yeah so you're saying what about
the friend what about that friend oh
yeah advice is hello Lawrence and T G
and guests my real name is mm-hmm but
you can call me whatever you want
we call him George George George okay
good good name we were just talking
about the Browns George yeah I don't
want to write I don't write to you with
a problem as such but I'm a man in need
of advice and I feel like the big man is
the perfect man to speak to I'm 19 years
old and I've been talking to this girl
just say he's
for a while now she wants to meet after
exams season is over and I think it'll
be more than friendship at 19 I've not
had a lot of sexual experience I'm 6
foot 4 and I would describe myself a
stocky this girl is plus size but not
fat and TG is always talking about how
he knows how to handle a bigger girl and
I was hoping to shape some tips share
sorry that my server
share some tips off his wise old head
how do you please a plus-size girls
exactly the same as a any other girl
really you just have to know how to
handle it you know right it's exactly
the same ones please in a normal girl
you just have to be strong enough to
foot in when you lift them up and you
throw them around you have to have a bit
of strength behind you see that I mean
and not a lot of men can handle that
he obviously has big lad you'll be fine
don't worry about it sure just be
attentive to her needs you know I mean
wow do you find there are different
needs for someone ever biggest I mean
there's some logistical issues
occasionally you know if it comes to her
claiming on top of the dick occasionally
that can be a bit awkward to guy well if
her thighs are on the large side they
might struggle to sit on top of him
depending on how wide he is as well
because if you're a wider man that can
cause issues as well and also you know
get your hands on our ass cheeks pull
them open how she's sitting down that'll
help as well she's a big ass girl
sometimes that's that's in need Jinna I
mean doesn't just slip right in like it
does on the petite girls right my name
is and I'm looking for your help I used
to see this girl who I really fell for
we grew a great connection for each
other and started to love one another
after a bit we broke up in that story
there which hurt me a lot before all
this she was going out with my best mate
for around 3 years [__] hell
they ended it and she started talking to
me
she then left me for him again several
three boned several times you took a run
because I loved her too much falling out
over this for over a year now we've
known each other for our whole lives she
was with him again for about four months
after she left me but they broke and
they've broken up now she's single and
I'm single
what do I do she's dipping [__] inside
her like just [__] sherbert it's
going in everything I think it's a big
world out there you know it's nobis
Hauser he was fine for me to say that is
it yeah yeah everything he said go back
to this girl don't lose a best mate over
it no we study not best mate if you to
it sharing if anything his MIT was with
her first for three [__] years yeah
your he other man in this MIT yeah you
see obviously he doesn't see that from
his own honor who needs to know that
he's part the problem he's the other man
yeah dude in him so steer clear of this
girl yes
top stairs yeah and you know mark that
off is done yeah mentally and physically
and get your best mate back I dealt at
his age he's in love I think he's just
you think he's just holding out of
option latest 119 is there an age limit
a love though
well I mean I don't think anyone should
be allowed to have sex over the age of
60 I mean over the age limit to sex I
mean love well I think it's very
difficult to know what the difference
between love is some people just simply
nobody sixteen and that's it on the you
know when you got these people who just
spend the whole lives together yes
recently I've had a bit of a problem I'm
16 year old lad and there's this girl
I've been talking to on snapchat you
talk to her on snapchat in there but all
of your conversations disappear yeah for
about half a year now yeah that's that's
it you know maybe she didn't like you so
much if it stays on snow but she doesn't
talk to me in person because she's too
awkward and recently she's been really
off with me he didn't put the quotation
marks on that but I did it also probably
doesn't help that she's best friends
with a girl I used to like a couple of
years ago who happens to hate my guts I
love the way that young people write she
really hates my guts I think she likes
me but I don't know if I feel the same
what should I do if you don't know you
feel the same you don't I I don't think
she's that keen considering she's off
and she hasn't moved past sunup chat yet
at MIT so I think you know he might be
overestimate in the situation like you
wouldn't do that to any of your friends
well what from the email person's point
of view yourself every guest without
Steven crux Lawrence up the most yeah
monteri funny word like no one said that
since 1995 yeah he's bringing Spice
Girls but he's bringing it all back
I'm 20 years old and I've just recovered
from attempted suicide caused by mental
health just I don't think this does not
go in the podcast
I think Stevens just fought and killed
himself easy dog like I understand where
you come from is the return we're all
kit with a feeling serious just not
right now yes open with you know at
least get the northern first when you're
on a roll of funny and then someone out
of nowhere thanks that you don't yeah
it's difficult time to come yeah yeah
yeah ok this is a new one I'm a twenty
year old guy living in the States going
to college I feel much better no we
didn't even get the hovers motion
answered yeah shall we go back and go
back
I've liked a girl for almost a year now
he's not gonna feel much better but
she's had a boyfriend most of the time
I've known it when we were first getting
to know each other I kissed her at a
party we were drunk but she seemed into
it I met her right before summer and did
not get to express my interest or she
went home for summer break and found a
severed boyfriend we've grown to be
close friends all this time and while
she had a relationship with her
boyfriend for the past year I've
recently found out they're separated how
long do you think I should wait to tell
her how I feel and how should I treat
this situation I want to know her will
would handle this and getting over her
breakup I think I love her and all make
this happen
I reckon we'll see it's one of those
when you guys love the podcast keep up
the good work
full stop I think I just you wouldn't
wait some guys are those snaky guys who
do that thing where they go that must be
really sad no I don't think wills that
kind of I know definitely that kind of
guy you're back yeah you're back and I
hate those kind of guys those guys who
like you guarantee they're like if a
girl has a larger with a boyfriend so if
she had an argument sure and she
delivers them Instagram really tried a
ghost
talking I notice you've got rid of your
boyfriend's pictures is okay
and then and she's there like not
actually I'm sort of quite a care and
considerate man and when it comes to
getting in but especially when women
need a shoulder to cry on tell us what
did he say is your yeah exactly that was
that the thought would never have even
occurred to me yeah how could he do that
ya know as you're worth more than that
you really are and if he doesn't know
that then you're best off without him if
she didn't originally get that just four
days after you'll just keep saying I
can't imagine another man treating you
like if that was me if that was and you
just said you don't my favorite blame on
that it makes me sick it makes me I
could be physically sick thinking about
other men treat beautiful women like you
like this and I'm just sitting here on
my own if I was with you I would have
took you out and I tell you what we
would be doing would be in the finest
restaurant yeah sorry he's not watching
sneaky guys you want to watch out for
because they would like that snap on you
oh yeah yeah have you ever had
experience with men like that making
moves I've known other guys who so the
reason I'm so passionate about it
because I know other sneaky guys who
have done that and
thought to myself I die if I see you
doing that with something like so they
did it within the group and there were
people dating across I said I was a teen
girl and another guy made him move
within group and if you could just tell
he picked his moment and once that man
Dave did that no no seriously though it
was a it was I remember thinking we
can't be friends anymore because if
you'll do that for a girl what what else
would you do you know what I mean you
can't trust people okay don't trust
those people that's my that's the bottom
line
do you want to help me pick a title yeah
I mean I've definitely picked the web
masturbation at the top there we've
looked at and thought of you that says
pretty good yeah and sex with one or two
yeah that's a good one I like the sound
of that
the girl I like has no dream sex is a
good one good okay we got oh five
non-election stories right first one is
called masturbation keep up the podcast
they're great wrong I feel that we're in
sync yeah I have a slight problem okay
okay I'm 19 and I've basically been
watching porn nearly every day so the
thing is now the [__] because we took
a break and we let him go got high on
the air
porn nearly every day for three years
now and I've come to the stage that we
stage where is watching porn every day I
need that shock factor recently I've
watched solo porn and the girl was
fingering fingering her ass and I tried
it myself
and liked it now I do it sometimes and
feel really guilty about it I just
wanted some advice about this as I am
still very much attracted to women and
think men are ugly but this has been
playing on my mind
is it big thing and should I be
questioning my sexuality all of the way
[Music]
unless you're actually fantasizing over
men I think the porn everyday thing for
three years nine hundred guys I think
for a period of my life I was I was
right up there and I was doing those
numbers every every single day for about
ten years
describe yourself was a prolific one
kill no I wasn't necessarily I wasn't
not I wasn't even one and over all the
time it might be like I'm just just in
cave if I had a shotgun a bunch I might
watch a little bit just to get just get
a little bit ideas and stuff and just
get off for it you know I mean thinking
about it some people do get inspired by
the things they watch inspirational I
said joerger was an inspiration earlier
or the other artists in other forms also
inspire us you know II dig a house in
them Alexis Texas she's favourably not
in the industry
why-why-why our asses the size of Texas
to be a massive Texas Holdem good let's
do this one this one is called sex with
one or two this is the last one like
it's a bit like tea one or two
wait let me just check out would you not
want to let we'll choose one because
we'll know the will has chosen these all
know spirits don't you worry about
Stephen ours on Stephens chose one what
about my mate some sixteen in your 11
exams coming up and I couldn't really
give two [__] about them I know we
should encourage young people to do stay
in school but that that just sounds like
me it's I'm just bothered about me
football I've been on and off with this
girl for about three years now
English by the way this emails for it
yeah I've been offered this girl now for
about three years and I love her because
we've had about sorry over two of them
them years together and I've not really
known now tells she's good-looking and
dead nice and we're supposed to be like
friends with benefits right now without
anyone knowing but she wants everyone to
know I think this is the anyway to the
point one of my good mates is talking to
this girl but he's been talking only for
a few weeks he's a virgin all that and
she's tapped a few lads I want to be
tapping her and she knows and she's told
me she wants to be and all but what
should I do
do I keep it to stop me mate and me
girlfriend and [__] her or do I just
leave it all and carry on the way it is
with friends with benefits with just one
girl I think he's actually including two
girls in this year I've got no I think
the situation he's described is he's had
a girl that he's been friends with
benefits with for a while now but now
his mate is started chatting to another
girl that he has
also had sex with and what he's trying
to do is keep both those girls free and
he's wondering does he go public with
the girl he's friends with benefits with
there is no for three years or does he
keep it all a secret and have the
benefit of sex from both of them
Wow that's what I some eyes from this
you should be a good Oh what you saying
we the thing is so if he just keeps
going the awesome earless flag to one of
them sooner or later
and if you're known one for three
actually that's a safer bet I mean we
don't know how much he likes them which
one I get it out yeah three years one
don't be greedy you're like God with two
it's like the dog you saw the bone in
the reflection and then yeah oh my god
yeah genuinely he just doesn't give two
[__] so he's trying to keep look I'd
look at you certainly get a window into
this blokes life in the 30s well well
playing like chaotic or something like
that I do also have I've got an email
here which does look looks juicy doesn't
it I've got time it's called pulling the
trigger on the time literally yet is
five plus five we've got to do that for
a deal sure and it is also I'm in year
ten inappropriate oh I'm one of four
hundred K subs sorry mate not answering
your question Lots
I know I really all use both really so
if you want us to do out on your travels
right especially for you one really so
if I'm not on their channels you know
this just as they which is fair enough
really yeah the channels both channels
oh you have been on my channel and you
can't go and do my channel see this
world's got two channels well it's got
two channels if anything all three of
the channels that the lads have got be
in the description below check them out
if you haven't already and
the ordered Lawrence no thanks I've come
down guys like the video thanks for
watchin
say is there